[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend der
Tag der Arbeit der für die meisten hier
arbeitsfrei ist hat ja eine bewegte
Geschichte ursprünglich war der erste
Mai für Arbeiter ein eher Angst
besetztes Datum am sogenannten moving
day liefen in den USA üblicherweise alle
Arbeitsverträge aus und man musste
zusehen wo man blieb notfalls auf
Wanderschaft gehen bis man einen neuen
Job fand mit einem Arbeitskampf in
Chicago 1886 begann dann die Geschichte
des ersten mai als Tag der
Arbeiterbewegung für Gewerkschaften
weltweit der Tag sich sichtbar zu machen
aber über dieses erste Mal Ritual hinaus
wie steht es aktuell um Macht und
Bedeutung der Gewerkschaften in
Deutschland dazu gleich noch ein
Gespräch nach dem Bericht von dort
entfernbar
die Faust geballt der Deutsche
Gewerkschaftsbund selbstbewusst am Tag
der Arbeit 2023
mehr Lohn und Gehalt lautet die
Forderung schließlich habe die Inflation
ein Loch in die Tasche gebrannt
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
weil eben klatschen und warme Worte
nicht reichen wir wollen für
hervorragende Arbeit auch endlich
anständig bezahlt werden
ungebrochen solidarisch so das Motto des
DGB in diesem Jahr es gilt zusammen sind
wir stark nach den guten
Tarifabschlüssen bei Verdi hoffen andere
auch auf mehr Geld und bessere Arbeit
aber müssen sie wieder Löhne attraktiv
machen im Baum
junge Leute die Bauarbeiten sollen ich
denke das ist noch ganz viele Bereiche
gibt in denen gute Arbeiten und
Fremdwort ist also der ganzen
Niedriglohnsektor vor allem aber auch
die freien und Selbstständigen denn wir
haben in Deutschland immer noch
Arbeitsverhältnisse die zeitlich
begrenzt sind viel zu viele
Arbeitsverhältnisse befristet Menschen
haben keine Perspektive in Koblenz
betritt der Bundeskanzler die
gewerkschaftsbühne Olaf Scholz hatte mit
einer Kampagne für mehr Respekt die
Bundestagswahl gewonnen nun will er den
erneut für jede Art von Arbeit auf dem
Bau im Supermarkt und Scholz appelliert
manche Betriebe suchen Händeringen
Fachkräfte
aus und deshalb hier und an dieser
Stelle der Appell es sollen sich alle
noch einmal
zusammenreißen und alles dafür tun dass
die Zahl der Ausbildungsplätze für
Deutschland weiter steigt
an diesem Tag der Arbeit gibt es
bewährte Kampflieder und zugleich einen
neuen Klang angesichts von Fachkräfte
überhaupt Arbeitskräfte Mangel
Gewerkschaften liegen wieder im Trend
wir erleben im Moment viel Rückhalt als
Gewerkschaften mehr Solidarität unter
den Beschäftigten auch ein Zuwachs
anvertrauen und das müssen wir natürlich
wir müssen wir auch gerecht werden dass
es gar keine Frage sie wollen mehr
Tariflöhne und dass diese Löhne dann
auch respektiert werden Tarifbindung
also auch der Staat müssen sich als
Auftraggeber dran halten es gibt viele
Forderungen an diesem Tag und es gibt
Gewerkschaften die heute neue Stärke
verspüren
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit Wolfgang
Schröder Professor für
Politikwissenschaften in der Universität
Kassel mit dem Schwerpunkt
Gewerkschaften er hat aber auch
praktische Erfahrung bei Gewerkschaften
gesammelt er war bei der IG Metall und
hat als Staatssekretär im
Landesministerium für Arbeit in
Brandenburg gearbeitet guten Abend Herr
Professor Schröder ja schönen guten
Abend
Gewerkschaften im Aufwind haben wir
gerade gehört wie stark ist dieser
Aufwind und wie nachhaltig kann man
schlecht sagen was wir feststellen
können ist dass durch den
Arbeitskräftemangel durch die Inflation
und vor allen Dingen auch durch die
Transformationsprozesse die
Gewerkschaften gebraucht werden und zwar
von den Beschäftigten an erster Stelle
die hohe Erwartungen auch haben
zumindestens dass die Inflation
kompensiert wird dass es ein Beitrag
gibt um die Arbeitsbedingungen zu
verbessern was vor allen Dingen im
Hinblick auf die Transformation ganz
wichtig ist weil durch die
Transformation werden fast alle
Arbeitsplätze verändert werden und hier
spielt das Thema Qualifikationen
herausragende Rolle vom Fachkräftemangel
Sprachen also der war ja im Bericht auch
ein großes Thema macht dass das nicht
eigentlich Arbeitnehmern wenn Sie
qualifiziert sind einfacher zu
verhandeln also sind sie dadurch nicht
eigentlich sogar weniger abhängig von
der Stärke von großen Gewerkschaften ja
für die hochqualifizierten trifft das zu
aber es gibt nicht nur hochqualifizierte
wir haben ganz großen Niedriglohnsektor
wir haben viele die gar nicht wissen wie
ihre weitere berufliche Karriere
verlaufen wird insofern sind starke
Gewerkschaften ganz wichtig als
kräftepartner als Gegengewicht zu den
Arbeitgebern die Arbeitgeber wollen die
Arbeitszeit verlängern die sind daran
interessiert die streikbedingungen zu
verhindern also es geht auch um die
gesamtgesellschaftliche Situation und
haben ja auch die Gewerkschaften die
streitbedingungen verändert mit diesem
Novum das erstmals zwei Gewerkschaften
sich quasi abgesprochen haben jetzt bei
den warenstreits
das war in der Taten Novum gewesen man
muss aber sehen in Deutschland ist die
streikäufigkeit relativ gering nach wie
vor selbst wenn man den Eindruck hat
durch die Streiks im öffentlichen Sektor
in der Infrastruktur das ist fast an der
Regel ist so ist der Vergleich dann doch
so dass die streikäufigkeit relativ
gering ist das hängt auch mit der
streikform zusammen weil im Zentrum
steht seit vielen Jahren der Warnstreik
und der Warnstreik der ist angekündigte
ist kurzzeitig der ist befristet und
soll dazu beitragen dass es ein
schnelles und gutes Ergebnis gibt aber
es gibt ja auch die Ankündigung
Kündigung eventuell dann innerhalb der
Gewerkschaften eine Gruppe nach der
anderen streiken zu lassen also man hat
da ja doch auch noch ein anderes
Instrumentarium oder andere Pfeile im
Köcher erwarten Sie das Gewerkschaften
künftig jetzt aus so einer Position der
Stärke heraus aggressiver auftreten
werden
das hängt von den Arbeitgebern ab wenn
die Arbeitgeber sich stärker wieder auf
das Prinzip der Sozialpartnerschaft der
Tarifautonomie festlegen gibt es gute
Bedingungen dass man die Herausforderung
der Transformation der Inflation
gemeinsam angehen kann wenn die
Zielsetzungen auseinander laufen dann
kann es in der Tat zu mehr Streiks zu
aggressiveren Streiks und zu neuen
Formen der Konflikte kommen nun gehen ja
Arbeitgeber auch nicht im luftleeren
Raum sondern auch vor dem Hintergrund
von zum Teil auch massiven Veränderungen
in Branchen also man sich verschiedene
Automobilindustrie ansieht eine
klassische Industriebranche wo eben auch
die Gewerkschaften stark waren die sich
ja nun aber auch verändert also wenn man
jetzt Anbieter wie Tesla guckt auch wenn
die hier in Deutschland bauen mit
Gewerkschaften hat der Herr Maske es
nicht so
das stimmt das ist aber für
amerikanische Konzerne nicht ganz
untypisch wenn man in die 50er Jahre zum
Beispiel gesehen als Ford in Köln sich
angesiedelt hat das hat über zehn Jahre
gedauert bis die im Arbeitgeberverband
gewesen sind so hat man viele Beispiele
von amerikanischen Unternehmen die
erstmal hier in Deutschland ankommen und
sagen wir bringen unsere Bedingungen mit
wir diktieren wie die Verhältnisse hier
zu gestalten sind und es dauert relativ
lange bis sie dann auch akzeptieren dass
die hiesigen Bedingungen anders sind und
anzuerkennen sind aber das betrifft ja
nicht nur Amerikaner der amerikanische
Konzerne auch in Deutschland gibt es
einen große Bereiche die
gewerkschaftlich gar nicht organisiert
sind die zum Teil nicht in
Arbeitgeberverbänden sind oder unter
anderen Bedingungen die sich an
tarifbindungen nicht halten kleine
Unternehmen Startups zum Teil Branchen
wie die IT-Branche die eben nicht diesen
klassischen Bezug zu Gewerkschaften hat
haben die Gewerkschaften da Chancen
überhaupt mehr Fuß zu fassen im Moment
haben sie erstmal Mitglieder mit den
letzten 20 30 Jahren massiv verloren ja
der Struktur im Handel der letzten zwei
Jahrzehnte wurde von den Gewerkschaften
nicht so beantwortet wie es vielleicht
möglich gewesen ist ist die Verschiebung
von der Industrie in den
Dienstleistungssektor von großen
Betrieben in kleine Betriebe von
gesicherten Arbeitsverhältnissen in
prekäre Arbeitsverhältnisse und wir
haben Deutsch in Deutschland in der Tat
ein
Organisationsgrad der im unteren Drittel
im internationalen Vergleich
mittlerweile ist und insofern ist das
was wir jetzt erleben so ein zartes
Pflänzchen der Hoffnung dass die
Gewerkschaften wieder stärker werden
weil man sieht ja die Politik braucht
die Gewerkschaften um die großen
Herausforderungen besser bewältigen zu
können die Arbeitnehmer brauchen die
Gewerkschaften und kluge Arbeitgeber
brauchen auch Gewerkschaften weil sie
damit mehr Sicherheit Planungssicherheit
und gute Bedingungen für sich selbst
schaffen können
das Gespräch
sehr gerne
wenn Branchen sich grundlegend verändern
ist das nicht nur für die
Arbeitnehmerseite und die Gewerkschaften
eine Herausforderung wer als Pionier ein
neues Produkt entwickelt oder
perfektioniert und das haben deutsche
Unternehmen immer wieder getan steht
natürlich erstmal fein da aber ohne
Ewigkeitsgarantie irgendwann kommt die
Konkurrenz aus innen und Ausland die das
Meer oder schneller oder billiger
produzieren kann oder ein Produkt hat
keine Zukunft mehr wenn die Zeichen der
Zeit nicht rechtzeitig erkennt kann auch
seine Arbeitsplätze irgendwann nicht
mehr retten vor diesem Hintergrund geht
Peter Kunst der Frage nach wie steht es
um made in Germany wie steht es vor
allem um die sogenannten hidden
champions also Unternehmen die nicht
jeder kennt die aber tatsächlich
Weltmarktführer sind
Deutschland Qualität
gummimembranen für Kläranlagen aus
Hannover geliefert nach China Indien in
die ganze Welt
Germany der 1975 hat mein Vater dieses
Produkt entwickelt
weltweit ein Standard im Bereich der
abwass geworden
Nischenprodukte oft kleine aber feine
Fertigung da ist Deutschland immer groß
gewesen
gummi-förderbänder für die
Möbelindustrie ein anderes
Spezialprodukt der Jäger Firmengruppe in
seinem Bereich gehört das Unternehmen zu
den Weltmarktführern 500 solcher
Champions made in Germany hat die
Bundesrepublik meist Mittelstand oft
Familienunternehmen immer gut vernetzt
mit der Forschung das deutsche
Erfolgsmodell aber es wackelt
wir haben einen hochsteuernland
Deutschland wir haben ganz viele
Menschen die bei uns im Unternehmen
Statistiken für analoge Behörden
erstellen in unseren ausländischen
Unternehmen sind die marien auch die
Gewinne wesentlich höher und mit diesen
Erträgen kann ich investieren
und manche der deutschen Unternehmen
sind zwar Weltmarktführer werden dann
aber von kapitalkräftigen
Kapitalgesellschaften aus dem Ausland
einfach aufgekauft
und dann wird die Entscheidung nicht
mehr in Deutschland getroffen ob ein
Produkt entwickelt wird sondern irgendwo
auf der Welt in der Welt gilt made in
Germany schon noch was als
Qualitätssiegel belegtes nach wie vor
Platz 1 aber heimische Firmenchefs
Vertrauen der eigenen Kraft immer
weniger in der aktuellen Umfrage für den
Weltmarktführer Index bewertet mehr als
ein Viertel made in Germany als
Auslaufmodell ein Weltmarktführer hat
das anschaulich beschrieben der Deutsche
ist vom tatkräftigen Anpacker zum
Zögerer geworden am besten alles
wasserdicht planen technologisch
wasserdicht wirtschaftlich wasserdicht
moralisch wasserdicht es wird so lange
geplant bis die geplante Innovation ein
anderer auf den Markt bringt deutsche
Innovation mit Mut und Risiko und ohne
Überregulierung umgesetzt davon steht
genug im Deutschen Museum in München der
erste Dieselmotor das erste ganz
metallflugzeug die Forschung zeigt dass
die Deutschen doch immer wieder die
Kurve gekriegt haben der Anfang von made
in Germany das war ja im späten 19
Jahrhundert
das verdickt das von den Briten made in
Germany Produkte schlecht und billig
sind und davon hat sich Deutschland sehr
schnell erholt und gezeigt dass das
Setzen auf hochwertige Technologien auf
ständige verbesserungsinnovation der
deutsche Weg ist solange uns hier die
Unternehmer nicht ausgehen die auch
etwas unternehmen statt zu unterlassen
wird auch Deutschland immer ein gewisse
Rolle in der Welt spielen wir sind eher
die kleineren nischenzuliefert die
Technologien entwickeln ohne dass die
großen Spieler aus Amerika oder China
gar nicht in der Lage sind ihre Ideen
global umzusetzen dafür beschäftigt das
Unternehmen in Hannover heute noch
Sattler wie seit 100 Jahren
spezialisiertes Personal um mit
speziellen Produkten auf neues
draufzusatteln so kann made in Germany
überleben
und wir sind Frankreich an diesem ersten
Mai Zugängen damit beginnen jetzt die
Nachrichten Hans dort gingen viele auch
auf die Straße um weiter gegen die
umstrittene rentnerreform von Präsident
macron zu protestieren die
Gewerkschaften hatten landesweit zu mehr
als 300 Kundgebungen aufgerufen und
sprachen von 2,3 Millionen Teilnehmern
nach Behördenangaben waren es knapp
800.000 die überwiegende Mehrheit
demonstrierte friedlich aber es gab auch
Ausschreitungen laut Innenministerium
standen den Ordnungskräften vor allem in
Paris Lyon und Nord extrem gewalttätige
Randalierer gegenüber
auch in Berlin hatten die Behörden
befürchtet dass es Ausschreitungen geben
könnte bei Kundgebungen linker Gruppen
am ersten Mai blieb es aber weitgehend
friedlich so wie im vergangenen Jahr
einige tausend Teilnehmer der
sogenannten revolutionären ersten Mai
Demo zogen vom Stadtteil Neukölln nach
Berlin Kreuzberg ein Großaufgebot der
Polizei war vor Ort vereinzelt gab es
Festnahmen
der Tübinger Oberbürgermeister Boris
Palmer ist bei den Grünen ausgetreten
das teilte die Landesparteien Stuttgart
mit zuvor hatte Palma nach heftigen
Reaktionen auf einen Auftritt am Freitag
angekündigt er werde eine Auszeit nehmen
Palma hatte auf einer
migrationskonferenz in Frankfurt am Main
einen rassistischen Begriff verwendet
als er danach mit Nazis rausrufen
konfrontiert wurde sagte er zur Menge
dass sei nichts anderes als der
Judenstern heute räumte Palme ein das
sei falsch und völlig unangemessen
gewesen
CDU-Generalsekretär Chaya hat
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck aufgefordert
in der Debatte und dessen Staatssekretär
reichen Konsequenzen zu ziehen habe ich
müsse Verantwortung zeigen und gleichen
entlassen sagte Chaya der Bild zuvor
hatte Schreie bereits in der ZDF-Sendung
Berlin direkt gesagt habe sei nicht
Vorsitzender der Grünen sondern der
Wirtschaftsminister der viertgrößten
Volkswirtschaft der Welt und müssen sich
entsprechend verhalten
energiestahlsekretär reichen war wegen
persönlicher Verpflichtungen bei der
Besetzung eine spitzenpostens unter
Druck geraten habe ich nannte das
Vorgehen einen Fehler betonte aber auch
reichens fachliche Leistung
russland hat in der vergangenen Nacht
erneut Ziele in vielen Teilen der
Ukraine beschossen in mehreren Regionen
fiel der Strom aus auch in der
Hauptstadt Kiew gab es Luftalarm die
Raketen konnten nach ukrainischen
Angaben aber abgefangen werden in der
Großstadt Pavlo Rad im Osten des Landes
wurden dagegen unter anderem Wohnhäuser
und Geschäfte getroffen mehr als 30
Menschen wurden verletzt darunter fünf
Kinder
Militärexperten vermuten dass die
russischen Attacken vor allem dazu
dienen die ukrainische Flugabwehr zu
erschöpfen und teils auch herauszufinden
wo dieses Thema stationiert sind
natürlich wird die Luftverteidigung eine
herausragende Rolle bei der von allen
erwarteten ukrainischen offensives
spielen Luftverteidigung dient ja nicht
nur dazu Gebäude und Zivilisten zu
schützen sondern auch Truppen und Panzer
wo und wie die Ukrainer vorgehen werden
darüber wird ja viel spekuliert etwa ob
sie sich auf eine Front konzentrieren
oder an mehreren Stellen gleichzeitig
angreifen zu den möglichen
Angriffspunkten gehört die Stadt wo die
da im Osten der Ukraine im Donbass
unsere Reporter daran
wir fahren zur Front bei wulleda hier im
südlichen Donbass hat die ukrainische
Armee Russland erhebliche Verluste
zugefügt nun könnte die Ukraine einen
Versuch wagen durchzubrechen im Zuge der
Großoffensive
regerverkehr an schweren militärischen
Gerät
artilleriegefechte gewinnt oft werden
Nachschub besser organisiert
es sind ukrainische Einheiten die feuern
die Ukraine ist der russischen
Artillerie hier mindestens ebenbürtig
auch durch die verstärkte gelieferten
westlichen Waffen
ich bin jetzt seit einem Jahr hier
damals hatten die Russen uns die ganze
Zeit beschossen und wir hatten kaum
etwas entgegenzusetzen aber in letzter
Zeit hat sich die Situation geändert
jetzt dank der westlichen Unterstützung
hat sich das Blatt getreten
inmitten der Front wohnt noch immer eine
Mutter mit Kind den evakuierungsaufrufen
sind sie nicht gefolgt über ihre
Beweggründe möchte sie nicht sprechen
für das ukrainische Militär sind
Zivilisten an der Front eine Belastung
ich verstehe dass es hart ist ein neues
Leben zu beginnen man braucht Geld und
Mittel aber alles ist besser als getötet
zu werden und Sie stehen uns im Weg wir
können nicht mit voller Kraft kämpfen
wir können unsere Artillerie nicht neben
ihren Eltern positionieren denn es gibt
gegen Feuer es wäre so viel einfacher
wenn sie nicht hier wären
in verlassenen Häusern werden häufig
Soldaten untergebracht meist kleine
Quartiere mit Küche und Bad Raum für
eine Handvoll Kämpfer
die zentral wird auch die Munition
gelagert damit ein Treffer nicht den
gesamten Bestand vernichtet
wir alle hier haben uns an die
Explosionen gewöhnt einfach an alles was
über uns fliegt wenn Du Dich ausruhst
und hörst dass es weit weg ist dann
kannst du dich weiter ausruhen
die Soldaten haben wochenlang hart um
das strategisch wichtige Bulle da
gekämpft bald könnte ihn auch noch die
große Offensive bevorstehen
dieser Krieg der geopolitisch gesehen
vor unserer Haustür tobt und die gesamte
europäische Sicherheit unmittelbar
bedroht hat andere kriegs- und
Krisengebiete in den Schatten gestellt
auf den Sudan etwa richtete sich unsere
Aufmerksamkeit zuletzt ja vor allem weil
die Rettung deutscher Staatsbürger
notwendig wurde oder anderes Beispiel
Afghanistan
Zulage dort tagt derzeit eine Konferenz
der Vereinten Nationen in Katar bislang
gibt es keine einheitliche Haltung wie
man dem Taliban regime begegnen soll
bislang wird die Weltgemeinschaft da
eher hilflos wie schlimm es für Frauen
und Mädchen in Afghanistan geworden ist
das sollte sich unsere Reporterin Katrin
Eigendorf mit eigenen Augen ansehen sie
traf verzweifelte die sich von der Welt
im Stich gelassen fühlen
es ist ein geheimes Treffen in einer
Wohnung in Kabul die VertreterInnen von
sechs afghanischen Frauengruppen haben
sich zusammengeschlossen sie fordern die
Welt dürfe die afghanenen nicht alleine
lassen Layla zeigt mir ein Video von
ihrem letzten Protest die Taliban haben
sie gewaltsam auseinander getrieben es
seien sogar Schüsse gefallen die junge
Frau hat an diesem Tag ihr Baby verloren
es ist die Verantwortung der Vereinten
Nationen für die Frauen und
Menschenrechte einzutreten wenn sie ihre
Büros in Afghanistan öffnen dann müssen
sie das kontrollieren und dafür arbeiten
sollen die Vereinten Nationen ihre Hilfe
einstellen auch um das Risiko das dann
Menschen hungern müssen eine Frage über
die sie heftig diskutieren der Westen
müssen notfalls seine Unterstützung
stoppen um Druck auf die Taliban
auszuüben meinen einige
Freiheit und Essen zu haben hat den
gleichen Wert für Afghanistans Frauen
wenn wir essen haben aber keine Freiheit
dann ist das inakzeptabel
in einem Einkaufszentrum in Kabul
treffen wir tabasum sie war Journalistin
bis die Taliban verfügten das Frauen nur
noch in besonderen Berufen arbeiten
dürfen im Gesundheitswesen und als
Lehrerinnen außerdem wurde ihr Sender
geschlossen die 22-Jährige jobt jetzt
als Verkäuferin doch auch das wird nur
geduldet weil es ein Geschäft für
Frauenbekleidung ist
wir leben in unserem eigenen Land und in
unserem eigenen Haus in Angst Morgen
können Sie mir verbieten zu arbeiten
heute können Sie es tun ich fühle mich
wie in einem Gefängnis
selbst die Gesichter weiblicher
Schaufensterpuppen und die Werbeplakate
müssen unkenntlich gemacht werden die
tugen Polizei der Taliban wacht darüber
streng ein Frauenbild das selbst kleine
Mädchen trifft
zu Hause ist aber Zoom die älteste
Tochter lange war sie für ihre vier
jüngeren Schwestern ein Vorbild sie
zeigt mir alle ihre Auszeichnungen und
universitäts-
wir brauchen die Unterstützung der
westlichen Länder ich persönlich brauche
sie dass sie meine Hand nehmen mir
helfen ich brauche kein Geld sondern
moralische Unterstützung
auch layla und die anderen Frauen haben
ihre Jobs verloren nur drei von ihnen
dürfen noch arbeiten sie sind
Lehrerinnen sie alle sind mutig so offen
Kritik zu üben denn eines wollen sie
sich nicht nehmen lassen ihre Stimme
zurück nach Europa zur Europäischen
Kulturhauptstadt gewählt zu werden hat
sich schon für viele Städte als echte
Chance erwiesen vor allem wenn
mittelgroße Städte gewählt werden die
auf der Liste internationaler Touristen
Hotspots nicht ganz oben stehen das
eu-siegel Kulturhauptstadt bringt
Medieninteresse und Besucher viele haben
daraus etwas gemacht Ideen entwickelt
sich einen neuen Anstrich gegeben das
will auch Chemnitz dass sich 2025 als
Kulturhauptstadt präsentieren wird für
die Stadt eine Chance auch das Negativ
Image als rechtsradikalen Hochburg
loszuwerden das umzusetzen wird
allerdings nicht leicht beobachtet
unsere Sachsen
30.000 Garagen gibt es in Chemnitz ein
kultureller Mikrokosmos wie an so vielen
Orten im Osten Deutschlands im
Kulturhauptstadtjahr 2025 sollen
garagenliebhaber wie Rike Drechsler ihre
Türen öffnen für Gespräche
Fotoausstellungen Projekte doch was er
genau machen soll welche Rolle die
Garagen spielen das weiß der
werkzeugkonstrukteur noch nicht also
äußerlich sieht man noch relativ wenig
also keine Kritik in dem Sinne aber
Anstoß dass man sagen kann jetzt müssen
wir doch das Zeug in der Hand nehmen und
zeigen unserem Volk oder unseren neuen
unsere Bevölkerung Virus sind die
Kulturhauptstadt in den Ofen Papier
groß war die Euphorie als Chemnitz den
Zuschlag bekam europäische
Kulturhauptstadt zu werden nach den
Rechtsextremen Ausschreitungen von 2018
sollte die Stadt wohl auch die Chance
auf einen Neustart bekommen inzwischen
hat sich viel frustbreit gemacht
besonders bei Akteuren der Subkultur
mangelnde Transparenz mangelnde
Kommunikation wackelnde Finanzierungen
so die Vorwürfe alle die hier irgendwie
mit dem letzten was er haben probieren
in Kulturprogramm zu schaffen die haben
sich natürlich gefreut okay das heißt
jetzt der Geldsegen das hat es aber
natürlich nicht bedeutet Chemnitz dieser
alte sächsische Industriestadt wo nach
der Wende so vieles kaputtging und die
Wunden noch immer nicht geheilt sind wo
die AFD stark ist und Montags stetig
demonstriert wird
man hat ein Buch geschrieben über diese
Stadt zwischen rechtsradikalen
Brennpunkt und Kulturhauptstadt das ist
nicht so dass
unfassbar viel mehr Nazis hätte als als
andere Städte das ist nicht unbedingt
der Fall aber wir merken schon dass die
radikale Rechte auch so eine gewisse
Resonanz stößt das ist
ganz
Normalisierung von Rechtsradikalismus
gibt die Macher der Kulturhauptstadt
stellen deshalb den gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt und den offenen Diskurs in
den Mittelpunkt ihrer Projekte um die
Lösung des Problems Rechtsradikalismus
sollen sich in das andere kümmern wir
sind dafür dass Menschen zueinander
finden wir sind dafür dass die Menschen
ihre Stadt besser gestalten wir machen
keine Politik die Politik ist aufgerufen
ihren Teil zu tun die Kultur und die
Zivilgesellschaft wird mit Projekten
beieinander stehen Projekte wie die
apfelpromenade 4000 Apfelbäume sollen in
ganz Chemnitz gepflanzt werden so sollen
Orte des gemeinsamen Verweilens
entstehen
es ist schön man gibt einen positives
Bild von der Stadt man zeigt dass die
Stadt sehr bunt sein kann sehr sehr
aufblüht im Moment gerade auch mit der
apfelbaumblüte oder in Verbindung und ja
dass man was man selber viel bewirken
kann wenn man im Kleinen mit anpackt für
Chemnitz ist der Titel Kulturhauptstadt
eine riesige Chance die Macher und
Menschen wollen diese unbedingt nutzen
und sich dem Rest Europas Bund und
weltoffen präsentieren
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter eins ja seit heute gilt das
deutschland-ticket mit dem der
öffentliche nah und Regionalverkehr
bundesweit genutzt werden kann wegen der
hohen Nachfrage war das Ticket teilweise
nur schwer zu bekommen es wird damit
gerechnet dass sich 17 Millionen
Menschen das von Bund und Ländern
finanzierte Ticket zulegen werden das
als monatlich kündbares Abo zum
Startpreis von 49 Euro verkauft wird
nach einer repräsentativen Umfrage die
ZDF heute zum Tag der Arbeit
veröffentlicht hat würde mehr als jeder
fünfte junge Erwachsene gerne kündigen
die Frage würdest du gerne deinen Job
kündigen beantworteten demnach 9% mit
auf jeden Fall 13% sagten ja ja die
Umfrage unter Menschen im Alter zwischen
25 und 34 Jahren entstand im Rahmen des
neuen zdf-formats soll ich die aktuelle
Folge soll ich meinen Job hinschmeißen
sehen Sie in der ZDF Mediathek
zum Sport der dänische radprofisörin car
Andersen hat den traditionellen ein
tagesklassiker Eschborn Frankfurt
gewonnen nach gut 200 km viel die
Entscheidung im Ziel brennt hinter
sörenker Andersen kam ein Patrick Konrad
aus Österreich und Alessandro fideli aus
Italien auf die Plätze zwei und drei
bester Deutscher auf Rang sechs war
Georg Steinhauser
als dritter deutscher Tennisspieler hat
Jan Lennart Struff beim ATP Masters
Turnier in Madrid das Achtelfinale
erreicht der 33-Jährige gewann gegen den
Serben Duschan lagovic mit 2:1 Sätzen
vorstroph waren bereits Alexander Zverev
und Daniel Altmaier ins Achtelfinale
eingezogen
und heute Abend dann die Entscheidung ob
als der VfL Wolfsburg in der
Frauenfußball Champions League schafft
ins Finale einzuziehen für das
Halbfinale Rückspiel mussten sie zur
Arsenal nach London es dauert ein
bisschen die Verlängerung aber am Ende
waren die Wolfsburgerinnen erfolgreich
die gute Nachricht für die
Wolfsburgerinnen Kapitän in Alexandra
poppner Verletzungspause wieder mit
dabei die schlechte Nachricht bereits in
der 11 Minute taucht Arsenals Dina
Blocks vor dem Tor der deutschen auf 1:0
für die londonerinnen nach dem
Unentschieden im Hinspiel hören Sie
damit im Finale das frühe Tor ein
Weckruf für die Wolfsburgerinnen in der
41 minute erzielte den Ausgleich aus 15
Metern unhaltbar in die rechte Ecke die
Partie ist wieder offen Trainer Tommy
strot fordert weiter so ein Halbzeit 2
Kapitän in Alexandra Pop setzt diese
Vorgabe vorbildlich um in der 58 Minute
erzählt sie das 2:1 doch Arsenal ist so
leicht nicht zu bezwingen Jennifer Beat
die mit dem zwei zu zwei Ausgleich ins
Spiel Minute der Fußball-Krimi geht
weiter und in die Verlängerung Pauline
Bremer schießt den VfL mit ihrem 3:2 ins
Champions League Finale dort treffen die
wölfininnen am 3 juni in Eindhoven auf
den FC Barcelona
und noch die Wetteraussichten morgen ist
es im Nordwesten freundlich sonst
entwickeln sich Schauer und Gewitter die
sich aber immer weiter nach Südosten
zurückziehen 10 Grad gibt es an der
Nordsee 19 Grad am Oberrhein am Mittwoch
regnet es noch mal im äußersten Südosten
sonst gibt es viel Sonne und die Luft
erwärmt sich bis Donnerstag auf 12 bis
24 Grad der Freitag bringt viele Wolken
Regen und Gewitter
das war es von uns an diesem ersten Mai
um 23:45 Uhr
weiter wir melden uns morgen wieder dann
gegen 21:30 Uhr in der Halbzeitpause vom
DFB-Pokal Halbfinale
[Musik]